dos manos inflables gigantes partiendo
un rifle por la mitad bajo el lema
queremos la paz centenares de personas
se reunieron para protestar al margen de
la conferencia de seguridad de Munich
exigen el fin de las entregas de armas a
Ucrania
es Sencillamente importante que no
podamos suministrar armas
permanentemente porque entonces la
guerra no se detiene Cada día que se
suministran armas muere gente de ambos
bandos y estas personas cuentan es
importante entablar negociaciones de paz
ciertos manifestantes afirman que el
dinero invertido en armamento y
belicismo podría emplearse mejor en
iniciativas de paz otros sostienen
carteles pidiendo la salida de Alemania
de la otan y banderas de las regiones
Rebeldes sirias y del kurdistán para
pedir el fin de la venta de armas a
Turquía
nuestro mensaje es que queremos que la
gente se resista a Las crecientes
Guerras que se están librando no solo en
Ucrania sino en otros países y que quede
realmente claro que el gobierno alemán
no debe continuar con el armamento con
la exportación de armas y la guerra
la protesta se cruzó con una
manifestación por Ucrania pidiendo
también la paz pero sobre todo ayuda al
pueblo ucraniano de parte de la Unión
Europea
en sus pancartas se puede leer Sin armas
no hay protección y dejen de matar a